okay so we take the top off without a
match the barking dog' experiment was
one of the most famous experiments and
favorite experiments that was done by my
former colleague clinical BD soul so
Neil Sam preparing for one of our
favorite reactions is called The Barking
Dog reaction this is a reaction which
actually makes an element and we're
going to make some sulphur today so the
reaction is quite quite cool in the
barking dog experiment you have a
mixture of the molecule carbon disulfide
cs2 it's just like carbon dioxide but
wait a minute
I mean so this is a test tube rather
last test tube of laughing gas into Oh
am I going to use that to make some
sulphur so I have a model here so it's
cs2 which has a carbon in the middle and
Sulphurs at either end so it looks just
like an ax model as a molecule of co2
but it has sulfur there and there and
this molecule cs2 will react with
laughing gas n2 oh in the dark somewhere
so essentially you're just using the
laughing gas as a source of oxygen to
burn this molecule what are we actually
we're going to do generates a lot of
light it used to be used as a flash for
cameras and photography what happens is
you get a very bright emission of a sort
of E and bluish purple light which in
the old days was used for taking
photographs before people had flash
lamps on their cameras they would set
this off and it would give a great flash
of light which could be used to take
photographs but because it's much slower
than the flash it makes people really
have quite a surprised look and this may
well be by an old way in old photographs
people look so surprised because my god
this thing has gone off whoosh that
we're on the hunt for a very dark place
in the tube
as the reaction takes place it generates
heat okay
so we'll come into the small lecture
theatre which is vacant now it's quite
nice because we can turn all the lights
off and make it a bit darker so you can
see this reaction and it's sort of best
so we've we've managed to to create a
darker environment so we can really see
the benefits from this chemistry and
Neil's put some water in the bottom of
the tube and we're going to put about
six to eight milliliters of carbon
disulphide into this tube and a good mix
so you can ensure that we get all of
that carbon disulfide going into the
vapor phase it'll react really quite
quickly with that oxidant Li into O as
the flame goes down the tube it
accelerates because the reactions going
faster and faster so it gives this great
sort of wood noise now then that was a
really really energetic reaction because
the organic and the oxidant are all in
the same phase and the reaction got a
lot faster and the noise it made when a
lot lot louder went down because of
pressure so what you can see in the tube
here is actually the result or the aim
of our chemical reaction today because
we wanted to make some sulphur so what
we've got here
coated on the inside of this tube is a
thin layer of polymeric sulphur so you
can see all this really quite nice
sulphur coating the side of the glass
flask itself now I'm really fortunate
because I'm just going to go back to my
office and prepare a lecture and leave
Neil to clean this
well juicy yeah well I've just filled up
my vessel with some oxygen so this is
liquid oxygen which we made for an
earlier demonstration and now we just
use it to to drive off all of the non
combustible nitrogen from inside this
glass vessel but I call that oxygen
floating around the bottom of that flash
that's really cool all oscillating and
really nice experiment yeah this is it's
a really quite crazy jar it's a small
amount of sulphur or suffer that we've
decanted Aten and unfortunately when we
decanted it out we spelled the name
wrong so who's responsible for that it's
a very old friend of mine and I couldn't
possibly give you his identity because
he'd be really really angry wouldn't
he'll send of it and he wasn't and it
wasn't Neal wasn't me essentially
so here we got a small amount of sulfur
that we're going to put on the tip of
this spoon so you can see it's starting
to melt over the top so it's on fire and
then we'll just drop it into the fire
and you can see that that sulfur's
burning really intensely now with a
really quite beautiful flame generating
a lot of so2 really smelly which is why
we're doing it inside this fume hood but
you can see the really rich intense blue
flame is that that sulfur is burning in
that excess oxygen atmosphere okay so
this is actually a sort of geological
sample of sulfur so you can see it's
actually on the bottom we actually got
what got a rock and the self crystals
have actually formed on top of it so
actually salt the does occur naturally
and I think it's been known since
ancient times and you know in sermons
are delivered with fire and brimstone
because the hell is supposed to smell
like sulfur which is brimstone actually
sold for itself and doesn't actually
smell but what you're smelling the
sulphur II smell is actually sort of
oxidized material and hydrogen sulfide
well it's actually a mixture of sulfur
and sand that was picked up by one of my
colleagues on his honeymoon you see he
was thinking about chemistry even on his
honeymoon
though I don't think he told his wife
that I have a feeling but I could be
wrong that this actually I bought this
sample in in Oxfordshire where I used to
live and I think it's actually from
Brazil I could be wrong
so as we using up all the sulphur now
the flame will die down until it
eventually go out cool there you go